je voudrais qu'on se parle aujourd'hui
d'un écran incurvé c'est le premier
écran incurvé de LG et c'est un truc
intéressant pourquoi parce que on
connaît énormément LG au niveau des
écrans au niveau des téléviseur bien
évidemment les connaît aussi au niveau
des moniteurs mais plats là c'est la
première fois qu'ils arrivent avec une
gamme incurvé qui est super bien ça
c'est un écran incurvé avec un carante 5
pouces que je trouve juste génial pour
le gaming bien évidemment plus que pour
regarder autre chose mais si vous
recherchez un moniteur gaming il se peut
que celui-là vous plaise alors je vous
le montrer je vais vous le détailler on
va tout savoir sur le taux
rafraîchissement sur les connectiques
sur la résolution sur la qualité globale
de cet écran je donnerai mon retour bien
évidemment à la fin sans oublier le prix
alors je vous donne tout de suite le
prix il coûte la modique somme de
1699 €, 99 centimes mais s'il y a
évidemment ce moniteur vous intéresse je
vous mets un lien d'affiliation en bas
dans la description
la première chose qui va m'intéresser
ici c'est cette diagonale 45 pouces en
incurvé c'est vraiment très très
impressionnant et le choix qu'a fait LG
ici c'est de vous mettre un rayon de
courbure de 80 cm qui vient imiter la
forme sphérique de votre œil surtout
qu'à l'idée qu'on vient de donner ici
pour avoir bien évidemment plus
d'immersion la résolution ici on est sur
du 3440 par 1440 pixels on se parlait
c'est une résolution wqhd et surtout
l'intérêt ici c'est que vous avez
affaire à une dalle OLED si vous avez
déjà eu un écran de LG vous savez que
les dalles sont bien maîtrisées alors
lolette c'est quoi ce sont des pixels
auto et missifs ce qui permet que chaque
pixel va être contrôlé indépendamment ce
qui nous permet lorsque vous avez une
partie noire sur l'écran bien c'est un
pixel qui était éteint donc c'est un
vrai noir ce qu'on appelle avoir des
Noirs profond puisqu'une fois de plus le
pixel est éteint et le contraste infini
et si cette qualité on va la retrouver
sur ce moniteur de LG faut dire que
s'ils ont vachement bien bossé leur
design avec des bords qui sont
extrêmement fins des quatre côtés donc
ça c'est très très cool une fois de plus
parce que ça évite d'avoir un truc très
massif très lourd avec de grosses
bordures ça ça vient très très bien se
fondre une fois de plus dans le décor
soyons clair ici c'est pas la première
fois que LG nous fabrique des moniteurs
donc ils savent le faire vous pouvez
l'orienter très facilement vers le haut
et vers le bas alors ce que je trouve
pratique c'est que lorsque je vais
mettre un petit pouce vous voyez ça
descend il y a une légère résistance au
début ce qui va me voir la solidité du
système on appuie un peu ça descend vous
le remontez un petit peu vers le haut ça
bouge un peu ça c'est bien donc très
réglable très facilement on peut
l'incliner vers le haut et vers le bas
pour pouvoir s'adapter bien évidemment à
toute configuration et à tout besoin
mais également sur le côté droite ou
gauche donc ça c'est bien parce que une
fois de plus ça va s'adapter un peu à
tout le monde et à toutes les pièces
après il est évident que de toute façon
quand on a un écran qui est incurvé
comme ça on va le garder face à soi mais
c'est petit réglages vous permettront
vous adapter par rapport à votre bureau
s'il est un petit peu trop ou un petit
peu trop bas et également par rapport à
votre chaise et pour trouver vraiment la
configuration au poil et le confort qui
vous conviendra le mieux pour venir
regarder votre contenu autre point
important ici vous avez une dalle entier
refait ça c'est vachement intéressant
une fois de plus lorsque vous êtes sur
un écran incurvé parce que ici j'ai des
sources de lumière de chaque côté et
lorsque je viens regarder comme ça voyez
et bien je suis pas du tout embêté par
les reflets je les vois pas ils sont
complètement invisibles alors tu veux
faire une démonstration ici j'ai un
éclairage forcément pour la vidéo vous
le voyez c'est un fl400 cinéroïde c'est
un peu fort et là lorsque je vous le
mets comme ça on le voit fatalement mais
parce que j'ai une source qui arrache un
peu la gueule mais si je prends ma
caméra à la main et que je viens me
déplacer devant une fois de plus une
source d'éclairage qui est juste
derrière là alors ça c'est l'éclairage
du haut c'est le cinéroïde mais si je me
mets comme ça vous voyez d'un côté là
mise à part mon cinéroïde sur le haut
sur globalement pas grand chose là je
devine peut-être un petit quelque chose
et même pas donc une fois de plus ça
c'est vachement bien ça ça vient
vraiment illustré le travail que fait LG
au niveau de sa dalle OLED mat on se
parle bien ici d'une Dalmat alors je
sais pas ce qui est Dalmat c'est trop
votre truc ça va dépendre il y a des
gens qui préfèreront peut-être des
choses un petit peu plus brillantes mais
bien évidemment le brillant forcément ça
va réfléchir davantage la lumière et une
fois de plus ça dépend de votre config
et leur bien souvent lorsqu'on est gamer
on se fait dans un espace où il y a
assez peu de lumière voler fermer rideau
tirer et on sera pas trop embêté par le
fait d'avoir des reflets mais si vous
êtes dans une pièce où vous avez un peu
de reflet ou si vous ne faites pas trop
lourd si vous et que vous voulez un peu
de lumière extérieure et bien comme il
est là avec la Dalmat franchement ça
fait le boulot bon ok ok maintenant je
voudrais bien qu'on revienne un petit
peu sur cet écran alors je vous l'ai dit
c'est du 45 pouces mais c'est également
du 21/9 c'est donc très allongé très
étiré ce qui est vachement bien parce
que si vous avez des jeux qui vont
rentrer dans ce format là vous êtes
peinard et là franchement tu as une
expérience vous êtes bien mais il y a un
autre point qui est extrêmement
intéressant c'est qu'ici vous pouvez
venir partager votre écran en deux avec
deux sources différentes et ça une fois
de plus c'est plutôt cool ce qui vous
permettra par exemple si vous êtes en
train de jouer un jeu et qui vous
demande plus d'informations et bien
d'avoir sur la partie gauche par exemple
un tuto sur Youtube ou autre très
facilement et sur la partie droite de
votre jeu vous allez pouvoir jouer
directement donc ça c'est quand même
plutôt cool ce multi-source c'est aussi
intéressant lorsque vous êtes streamer
et que vous voulez venir avoir deux
sources différentes et afficher deux
sources différentes ça peut être pas mal
aussi donc ça je trouve ça aussi assez
malin autre chose à savoir pour les
gamers vous avez ici un taux de
rafraîchissement de 240 Hertz qui vous
apportera beaucoup de fluidité pour vos
expériences de gaming tout ça avec un
temps de réponse de 0,03 millisecondes
donc vous avez la combinaison wqhd plus
d'un côté avec le 240 Hertz qui vous
apporte une bonne expérience de gaming
alors ça vous l'avez grâce au HDMI 2.1
mais également grâce au DisplayPort
puisqu'on parle de Porsche n'est qu'on
regarde les connectiques derrière pour
voir si effectivement vous avez le
nombre de connectés qui pourraient
correspondre à vos besoins alors
regardez vous allez avoir déjà deux HDMI
2.1 le premier j'ai utilisé ici pour mon
PC et vous avez le deuxième qui est
juste là on va se retrouver aussi de
l'autre côté vous avez votre port
secteur bien évidemment ici vous avez
deux
USB 3.0 juste ici vous avez un
DisplayPort vous allez avoir une sortie
optique ça c'est intéressant autant vous
dire qu'ici en nombre de vous avez
globalement ce qui va bien alors autre
point à venir voir et vous le voyez
peut-être derrière ça c'est très cool
c'est que vous allez avoir des bandes de
LED de chaque côté donc ici de ce côté
là et j'ai exactement la même qui se
situe de ce côté là alors là je vois que
sur l'iPhone on voit un espèce de
clignotant scintillement qui fait un
petit peu violet bleu sauf que moi j'ai
une espèce de couleur violine fixe j'ai
pas du tout avoir le même rendu que j'ai
sur l'écran de mon iPhone tout de suite
donc j'ai une bande un petit peu violine
violine bleue qui est assez homogène ici
donc je l'ai effectivement de ce côté et
comme je vous le disais je l'ai aussi de
ce côté-là et autre point à venir
connaitre également on va venir regarder
plus par en dessous ici vous avez une
prise jack qui situe par ici ce qui vous
permettra de venir connecter un casque
très facilement casque micro casque
d'ailleurs pour la petite info votre
moniteur est compatible Nvidia G5 et AMD
free 5 premium alors normalement j'ai
une télécommande qui est livrée avec
c'est la télécommande ultra gear qui me
permettrait de venir naviguer ici dans
les différents paramètres que je vais
avoir au niveau de mon moniteur au
manque de bol ici moi c'est un prêt
presse et je pense que la personne qui
l'avait avant moi a oublié de remettre
la télécommande donc j'ai pas la
télécommande mais si vous vous le prenez
en tout cas vous aurez une télécommande
et si toutefois vous perdez votre
télécommande il y a une petite astuce
pour va venir naviguer très facilement
je vous montre en fait vous avez un
petit bouton qui vient se positionner
juste en dessous et vous allez être
guidé par cette petite lumière donc là
vous voyez vous venez poser votre doigt
là et ça vient déclencher le menu donc
sur le menu je vais avoir power of input
volume hub volume donne brightness up
British down je viens naviguer en
appuyant une fois là je peux choisir mes
entrées régler le volume baisser le
volume montez le volume montez la
luminosité baisser la luminosité si je
fais un appui long je valide et ensuite
là vous voyez je refais un appui long ça
me sort du menu et ensuite je peux
naviguer je peux venir ensuite
sélectionner mon entrée ici par exemple
je fais un appui long HDMI 1 HDMI 2
DisplayPort de la même manière je fais
un appui long je sors et hop je sors du
menu et au bout d'un moment on touche en
rien et bien voyez le menu s'envole
lui-même alors moi j'aime bien ce
moniteur parce que je trouve très très
bien conçu en plus de ça vous avez un
petit Pascal à l'arrière qui va venir
récupérer bien la voyez mon HDMI ici et
mon câble lime alors bon là c'est un peu
le bazar parce que j'ai pas beaucoup de
longueur mais sinon vous le descendez
directement derrière c'est plutôt bien
en plus je trouve très élégant très très
bien fait les matériaux sont assez jolis
très facile à venir installer vous avez
juste à venir Clipper cette partie là
avec la petite modulaire qui vous
permettra de venir le bouger très très
facilement et lorsque vous voulez le
défaire et regardez on pousse ça vers le
bas et il va venir sortir directement
donc ça c'est très très très facile et
une fois que vous avez installé ça et
bien vous avez plus qu'à venir visser
cette petite partie là juste en dessous
donc en termes d'installation il est
vraiment très très très simple et après
il vous le montre ici alors je voulais
pas préciser mais au niveau de
l'écouteur vous êtes en DTS x le design
super chouette avec ce pied qui est
vraiment très très fin et très élégant
des bordures fines une très belle
qualité d'affichage donc si vous voulez
un beau moniteur de gaming pour venir
jouer à vos jeux bien évidemment il fera
franchement l'affaire alors là je vous
parle de moniteur de gaming mais vous
pouvez également venir l'utiliser pour
venir travailler si vous voulez faire du
multitâche pour ce globalement ici vous
avez de quoi faire avec ce grand 45
pouces donc il y aura un usage qui sera
un peu mixte à la maison et une fois de
plus le point positif surtout que je
viens retenir ici c'est qu'on est sur
une dalle OLED signée LG et une fois de
plus LG maîtrise extrêmement bien ces
dalle OLED qui sont une des références
dans le domaine aujourd'hui donc si vous
cherchez un très beau moniteur de gaming
et bien vous pouvez aller sur celui-là
une fois de plus je l'ai assez cher on
est à 1699 9 9 pour être très précis
mais bon pourquoi pas si vous voulez un
beau setup et vous faire plaisir ça
pourrait franchement faire le Tab
d'ailleurs je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez est-ce que ce moniteur pourrait
vous plaire marquez moi ça bien
évidemment dans les commentaires et puis
on reparlera de gaming là je vous ai
branché un PC à côté de Asus c'est le
ROG Strix scar 16 je vous en parle
également sur Youtube donc si vous
voulez vous équiper et vous faire
plaisir vous voyez il y a globalement de
quoi faire et là vous avez un combo il y
a même plutôt pas mal voilà allez je
vous embrasse prenez soin de vous et à
très bientôt Ciao